من خلال الخطوات لماذا فعل Don jr.  افعل
هذا الاجتماع دون جودي مع روسيا
نعم ودون الابن.  فعل هذا لإقناع
والده لأنه أراد الإطاحة بكوري
ليفاندوفسكي وتولي الحملة
، وقال ستيف لذلك كان عليه أن
يُظهر لوالده أن لديه هذه الأشياء ، لذا
كان هذا بالتأكيد عن Don jr.
عندما أجريت مقابلة معه ، هل كنت
تفكر يا رجلي الذي كان السبب في
ذلك بالتأكيد لأنه أمر
مزعج تمامًا ، لا يمكن للرجل أن يذهب ، ضع
جملة متماسكة تلو الأخرى ،
لا يمكنه البقاء في الموضوع ، هل تعتقد
أنه على وشك  ثم تعود
إلى نفس الشيء الذي
قاله قبل خمس دقائق وهو يقول الآن
مرة أخرى ، هل تعتقد أنه من الجيد
أن يشكك الناس في لياقة
رئيس للولايات المتحدة الحالي
أعتقد أنه سيكون تصرفًا
غير مسؤول لا  بالطبع
أعتقد أن الجميع
مذهول بإعلانك أن مائة
بالمائة وهذه كلماتك مائة بالمائة
من الأشخاص المحيطين بالرئيس
يعتقدون أنه غير قادر
على أداء واجبات هذا
المنصب مائة بالمائة إنه كذلك
مذهل لهذا السبب أعتقد
أن هذا هو السبب في أن هذا الكتاب قد ضرب مثل هذا
الوتر ، يدرك الجميع أنه
خارج البيت الأبيض ومن
الواضح أن التفكير في إدراك أن
الناس  داخل البيت الأبيض الذين يشبهونك
تمامًا وأنا أقول
ما هذا بحق الجحيم